good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast a year and a day later
today is Wednesday oh my god that daily
for Coachella tomorrow and truly I'm not
prepared emotionally I also have no
clothing but like that's less what I'm
worrying about just because like the
idea of being in the desert is something
that takes a lot of preparation for me
as a Jewish person it's a scary thought
Angelia I think I threw out accidentally
a belt that I really needed like I got
it I took it to the cleaners to get
extra belt holes nothing like more
satisfying being like the belt doesn't
fit and it came back door that swings
both ways cuz you could need to get
extra holes in them yet no no no it was
in the front all right yeah
smaller made smaller and I got in the
back from the dry cleaners with other
stuff I guess and I must have missed it
in the bag and I threw the bags away and
this morning I went to the trash and it
wasn't there and I was like well I can't
believe we've been sitting here for 20
minutes and I'm just now realizing
you're wearing a [ __ ] but of course I
am because those have changed my life
they really have well speaking of [ __ ]
bows if you haven't gotten your merch
yet the merch store will be up for a few
more hours
shop morning just calm everyone I'm in
no rush everyone either of $50 or more
gets a free champagne chalice and it'll
be a good time so I'm just talking like
Game of Thrones like last night I was
being so crazy like because I've been
catching up on Game of Thrones and you
really get into the vernacular so like
in bed less and I was like then I am the
throne of the Iron Islands because I'm
watching Theon Greyjoy now because Theo
is the throne of the iron island he
really is he's the rightful heir what is
dead may never die
he is Theon Greyjoy it's crazy him and
scheana have so much in common
stop with so Ian feels better than that
I know but you know what like Theon has
his redeeming moments too what kind of
preps do we have to do for Coachella
just to make sure like I have a check
let's I'm getting a manicure pedicure in
my lip waxed and then we're getting our
eyebrows waxed I would have liked to get
a lash tint but my salon that we go to
is in like Jensen to the rainbow and
literally as like this week no one could
take me in a spray tan tomorrow we have
spray tan tomorrow and then the rest is
just you know a positive attitude that's
gonna be the hardest thing to ever get
my [ __ ] bleached because that seems
like less pink yeah yeah they're putting
on a smile in the desert you'll have to
shave your legs before the tan yeah
exfoliate
mm-hmm all the stuff but then the tan
covers up like all the other problems
that you would have to be infectious
joint like the loss of ten pounds right
and also just like the general texture
yes malaise you know yeah and then all
your clues just look a little bit better
yeah but I'm really upset about this
belt because oh sorry because the belt
was part of um a fanny pack
it was the belt and then you slide the
pack on like it's not a fan oh so now
you look back now I have this pack and I
don't know about to put it on so I guess
I have to go shopping that's what you
get in anyone want to come that's what
you get for being thin I know you know
it's fine I'll get my nails for
Coachella
that's a yawn I'm thinking a plain e I
think I'm gonna have a whole plain e
vibe the whole weekend think of like
your best outfit and then have your
nails match that so people be like she
was so Gordon well it's so hard because
like I barely have one good outfit well
regardless we have a busy day today and
we're obviously going to deliver in the
past five we have a guest block a
horseman and I finally understand why
it's palaka and it's funny it's I'm
scared haha okay you know what
and you know I will say this before he
gets here because I could never come
from him to his face but you know the
name Jacqueline is also referencing
that's hit Jay Quellin and I would never
make that my Instagram handle especially
after being runner-up on The Bachelor
but now I'm a public figure like change
your names no I'm just gonna change your
name for totally it's time for a private
citizen it but also like there's a
certain type of person who like makes
jokes about old skits do you know what I
mean no and makes Instagram handles bad
old skits and sticks to them even after
how many Instagram powers yeah like so
many like five hundred thousand too many
so now that I know that he's that type
of person like I'm wondering if we're
gonna vibe also snitches here because
she just wanted to meet him and I feel
like as it'll be a really good thing I
think maybe we'll make a match it
sportsmen a Jewish last name I don't
think so that's not not right there men
are Jewish let go man
Gold man yeah spider-man so we have a
chance yeah there's a chance so I'm
saying there's a chance but before we go
into matchmaking we do have one brief
task and that is to deliver the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast also we recorded
an episode with the skinny confidential
heads in her podcast yesterday and it
was really good so with just look out
for that yeah I think she that I think
we have some time okay yeah but it was
it was a fun one
okay first story and update and
operation varsity blues Lori Loughlin
and her husband have been hit with new
charges in college admission scam bad
boys so Felicity Huffman took you know
her oh she took her troops and they pled
guilty they took a plea deal so she's
really moving forward like she's she's
in she's at house guilty yeah Lori
Loughlin and Massimo are of house not
guilty and I guess in their plea deal it
was said if you take this deal you'll
face up to 48 months in prison but we
will not file additional charges ago and
they didn't take that deal they didn't
take that deal and I guess like sources
are saying that they are not taking this
seriously and now with them so they
didn't take the deal and now the
additional charge additional charges
have been filed which was like money
laundering and now they could face even
more time in prison there's each of the
two charges against a couple carries a
maximum of 20 years Wow and they're
going to jail like unless they have some
magical boyer actually these days no one
good no I mean it have anything it's so
like crazier things have happened
like Johnnie Cochran Oh Jay Simpson
right truly it's Oliver loyally the
first time right it's all about a good
lawyer yeah I was like what's Robert
Shapiro up to these days and I say what
abusive I surprised if he's defending
some people in this case you know oh my
god totally but he's also very busy with
his shoe empire over at ShoeDazzle I
wish that Roberts that lawyers like
especially public really public
celebrity ones like they were like PR
people where you could see how their
client ya know but it's actually the
opposite I think you can but I don't
think it's for criminal cases like every
celebrity has like an attorney for like
their deals like to negotiate and that's
public because like on IMDB Pro and
things like that you can see that like I
have an attorney but if I got arrested I
would call that ya know but I guess if
you go to the courts you could the
filings you could see who the lawyer
yeah or if you just like watch the
paparazzi pictures of them walking into
court you can see if you recognize their
lawyer Lisa bloom because she's always
on a daily pop but I don't think I would
recognize Robert Shapiro because I'd be
waiting for a John Travolta
right and then I would be disappointed
not to see John Travolta right it's you
know my feelings about John Travolta are
so weird so mixed because I'm not gonna
lie like I adore him like door to me
he's Danny Zuko he's Robert Shapiro he's
the greatest actor of our time he's
acuity him and Kelly Preston
he's um he's [ __ ] at
Turnblad oh thank you yes but then at
the same time it's like I know so much
about John Travolta in a very negative
way and like the blinds about him are
very legit and I read a little while ago
this huge statement from someone who one
of the John Travolta's victims who was a
masseuse in a hotel in Philly who just
like hired him to massage and he was
assaulted and like it's so crazy like I
with like are Kelly and Michael Jackson
for me it was like cut it off but John
Travolta has been into so many like
movies that shaped my child to them it's
like I forget yeah I saw a picture of
Amy she just head I'm like oh what a
cutie I'm like no not a cutie
not at all nothing cute about it yeah I
think we need to do more remembering
when it comes to John Travolta people
seem to be forgetting but there has been
like no so no nobody about it no it's
nothing to me even talks about it's like
there's been no documentary there's a
didn't even ill case I didn't even read
a story the guy who who spoke out
released a statement on his own Twitter
he didn't want any people press he was
just like this happened so that's when
it's difficult to galvanize that the
country because you know we need a
documentary that's true though there was
a lot more proof string together in a
pretty documentary for us for other
cases that's like that's okay jack man
comes how about John Travolta that's
compelling I will I will turn knew
totally but there's something like about
him that I just that that makes you
forget yeah no I think that's than the
Scientology that we're all like
struggling with as a culture is these
beloved figures who are monstrous yes I
thought you were gonna say Scientology
that's just another layer to the
weirdness you know he's really high up
in in the Sea Org him and Tom Cruise are
like top donors and when me and Martha
were in Clearwater we were talking like
every bird driver about it cuz it's
literally all the people all the the
only thing that people in Clearwater
talk about and there's like another
level because the people who like Jar
Jar alternate Tom Cruise to give money
to the Sea Org because it's technically
like a church you don't pay tax on it
and it's like a form of tax evasion it
but it's legal there exactly once III
yeah it's like I think I don't know that
we can ever take down Scientology but
let's talk about how their 501c3 well
speaking of 501 C 3 is did you see
Elisaveta pork chop is live but we're
going to talk all about it she was being
bizarre she was being publicist no I
thought she was being like a little bit
unhinged and like if you if you're able
to even if you're a scan if you could
just look at it for a second I'm like
this woman is a liar not a liar it
seemed like she had lost her marbles a
little bit because there was one one
conversation where her and Andy we're
taking English but they weren't speaking
the same language because he was like
well the article was really written very
positive about you the radar online it
seemed to swing in your favorite that's
why everyone thought it was written by
you she goes but I don't need negative
press like that but any was like no no
but it was a positive articles you know
attributing all the work you do and
other positive things that the
organization does she was okay but I
don't need negative press like that they
were literally just not on the same
planet agree do you see my story then
yes it's hilarious I mean Lindsey Lohan
making no sense for doing it in an
accent and wearing something weird on
her head told that that was everything
Lindsay Lohan made her show to become
like Lisa Vanderpump meanwhile Lisa
Vanderpump is slowly retracting I'm
becoming Lindsay Lohan totally must be
something about being a restaurateur
yes gets to you um anyways keeping you
posted this is really serious about Aunt
Becky she it's very serious and it's
that's not good that some sources are
saying they're not taking it seriously
yeah I mean of like they'll probably say
that but I feel like she knew you just
said that that's why I said it no but I
mean they will like they can say and say
anything but I do feel the way like I
feel the way the chief I feel like she
might have felt the way we did in the
beginning there's no way people are
gonna go to jail for this and so she's
not gonna take a plea because there's no
way she feels like she should go to jail
right but it's getting so much worse but
it's getting worse and I know that she's
not taking it seriously that this is a
crime punishable by jail if you're
guilty you always take a plea deal only
people who are innocent feel like they
really want justice no I didn't do this
I don't want the plea deal let's go to
trial but she is you know so obviously
guilty that the fact that they didn't
take the plea deal is so crazy I feel
like you could argue argue the opposite
though why like if you're innocent like
it just depends on how the trials no
because if you're innocent I'm not gonna
take a pill that that puts you in jail
for a smaller amount of time if you
didn't do anything and nobody it's so
sad because just the criminal justice
system is is a wonderful and it's also
so flawed and you can't guarantee your
innocent doesn't mean necessarily that
you will be proven innocent there are so
many factors that place if someone who's
what I'm saying you know what it might
take
Livio cuz like they don't have the facts
to back them up like for sure for sure
but nobody very rarely would an innocent
person take a plea deal if they didn't
do it you know mm-hmm like that's just
logic
so there's so much evidence against them
she knows she did it like she knows
she's guilty so passing on a plea deal
is really odd that's like a really bad
legal advice unless they unless they
don't know or they think that a jury
will be swayed by Aunt Becky maybe in
the room you know but then they're also
just prolonging this whole thing for
them and their kids agreed also I saw
another story that her daughters are not
allowed to withdraw from USC okay but
what does that mean like they're holding
them like the prisoners the University
of Southern California won't allow Lori
Loughlin daughters to drop out of school
despite allegations their aged parents
pride the girls way into getting their
Olivia Jade and Isabella G a newly
remain enrolled at the University of
Southern California which put holds on
the accounts of all students did she
just storm out no I think Blake arrived
freshman I just some of this tell her
we're doing a live show to stop slamming
the door so she made sure to say in the
door behind you
twice could this prevents the students
from registering for classes until they
have agreed to participate in the review
of their case withdrawing from the
university or acquiring transcripts
while their cases are under review the
college said in a Monday statement but I
feel like any college can't stop anyone
from withdrawing you know it's like it's
not prison you know this is really good
no but it's also like they're not minors
I can camp if you wanted to leave camp
as a kid you couldn't yes your parents
gonna pick you right but like if you're
a college student you're over 18 you can
leave whenever you want yeah it's really
weird
they will keep you here till 4 we can't
keep him back door well yes a criminal
justice system it is flawed but you know
sexually based offenses are considered
especially heinous
and in New York City the dedicated
detectives who investigate these vicious
felonies are members of a sip enza's are
considered especially heinous
in New York City the dedicated
detectives who investigate these vicious
felonies are members of an elite squad
known as the Special Victims Unit
these are their stories dun dun okay
sorry I just like that's never happened
to me before like I've never stumbled
over my words I think this is also a
good thing because I think that they
should stay in college if I was their
friend
that's what I would tell them to do they
have two options and they just need some
good friends yeah walk with them
yeah they have two options here one they
can you know go to college because it's
looking like they might need to start
making some money on their own or they
could just download Robin Hood and
invest start investing and start
investing that's a great way just to get
your portfolio up
who needs college when you have Robin
Hood because Robin Hood is an investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
and ETFs
options and Kryptos all commission-free
while other brokerages charge up to ten
dollars for every trade Robin Hood
doesn't charge any Commission fees so
you can trade stocks and keep all of
your profits plus there's no account
minimum deposit needed to get started so
you can start investing at any level the
simple intuitive design of Robin Hood
makes it easy for newcomers and experts
alike Robin it is giving our listeners
of the morning toast a free stock like
Apple Ford or sprint to help you build
your portfolio sign up a toast dot Robin
Hood dot-com that's toast Robin Hood
calm for a free stock from Robin Hood
just for our listeners don't say we
never gave you anything
okay next story is really exciting a
little nerve-wracking because like
everything is ruined these days but
Camila caballo to star in a new
cinderella movie I saw singer/songwriter
Camila caballo will star in
writer-director que canons of pitch
perfect yes retelling of Cinderella /
Sony Pictures Cabello will be involved
in the music for the project which grew
out of an original idea from James
Corden the film will be produced by
Corden and Leo Perlman through their
full well 73 banner the new Cinderella
will be a music oriented version of the
traditional tale of the orphaned girl
with an evil stepmother okay I know I
love James Corden this is hardly an
original idea yeah but I do love how
James Corden getting involved in musical
theatre because I feel like I didn't
really know that he was like such a
performer until carpool karaoke where he
started like harmonizing perfectly then
I learned a little bit more about his
background and he doubt he has a big
like theatre background and I think
he'll be good on this he's also doing
cats with Taylor Swift
they're filming in London so I'm just
loving him like dipping his toes into
other projects and I love Camila Cabello
for this role like she is she really is
like a no matter we make fun of her cos
like she always looks drunk but at the
end of the day she's so talented and
when I watched her on x-factor like I
thought she was too good for harmony
back then and she truly is and just like
watching them all do their like sad solo
careers like it's just proof that like
coming like it was always too good for
them like look at her like opening for
Taylor Swift like we've been saying for
a while now
she's strong but like she's still going
so right maybe she's just like one of
those in the pudding and it's like she's
okay
like she seems okay she seems okay and
no I'm really a fan of hers so I think
this is great I'd love her expanding her
her career into the acting field while
also you know relying on her strong
vocal chords for the Cinderella songs
and I think this is great and when I
heard it I was like yes okay I just want
to point out like but she'll never be as
good ready I want to point out one
interesting factoid cuz it says the best
on Cinderella movies have been Disney's
animated drama released in 1950 and to
live-action remakes 1997's version
starring Brandi and Whitney Houston and
the 2015 film with Lily James and Robb
Stark yes and okay I just want to say I
don't know why that movie like went
nowhere nowhere it's why wasn't it
Beauty and the Beast live-action remake
like why why is it literally because
they cast truly like Cinderella and
Prince Charming right
and then also lest we not forget there
have been a couple Cinderella remakes
that aren't mentioned here a Cinderella
story another Cinderella I don't think
those are like connected to the
Cinderella franchise but like they are
and they keep making those uh
made-for-tv made-for-tv Cinderella
movies and they're amazing
like the Selena Gomez one so good I'm
pretty sure there was one with Lucy Hale
so good the Selena Gomez one is another
Cinderella story
and then the Hilary Duff one is a sound
sister I don't think either of them are
actually part of the franchise which is
why they weren't mentioned but I do have
to agree with you that like the 2015
version which was slated to be like just
as big as Beauty and the Beast like
didn't go anywhere and why didn't nobody
care that Richard Madden the hottest man
alive was Prince Charming and then
there's a Cinderella story once upon a
song with Lucy Hale and it's great and
everyone's got oh but those aren't
considered to be included in the
franchise but it's like and I don't
think if you if you put them all
together a Cinderella movie comes out
every year yeah I also love like how
many celebrities get involved in the
Cinderella story telling like Cinderella
on Broadway had nene leakes and it also
had friend treasurer and then we had
this Selena Gomez Hilary Duff of it all
then we had Whitney Houston and Brandi
like truly icons so I just really am
appreciative of the Cinderella franchise
like respecting the hell out of
celebrity chimein like Ella Enchanted
was she part of soon to know and then if
you watch descendants
what's Cinderella's daughter's name
counsellor descendants aubrey
descendants three trailer descendants
three so i'm guessing it's not in
theaters for anyone who's a descendant
fan or a parent of a descendants fan
yeah you have a better luck with that
yeah it is it is so good it is so good
I'm so excited for defendants three I'm
excited for you
Kenny Ortega um but just really quickly
back to the coming with Aveo of it all I
also think just like her as a woman is
snatched like I'm really looking forward
to her in that corseted blue dress
you know heroness and young the whole
thing we only get that for like thirty
seconds at the end she's like in a broom
closet
yeah totally no but she goes to the ball
too ya know what I'm saying that's the
thirty seconds at the ball at the end
it's like the end yeah yeah yeah
frustrating I'm just I'm excited I
wonder who's gonna play the evil
stepmother
hopefully Jennifer Coolidge yeah she's
so good at it ya know okay that's an
that's an interesting role to cast
because it has to be someone of a
certain age but also someone who's good
at playing evil like Jennifer Gardner
can ever do it she's America's
Sweetheart you know who's someone who
has like a lot of experience playing a
villain I don't know but like I haven't
thought about it I haven't thought about
it either but this will be good
honestly they need like a real hospital
in there nene leakes honestly they need
Heather Dubrow wow that's such a good
call I think there's an actress yeah
that's what I'm saying
interesante and she's still good at like
looking down on others I'm not opposed
okay all in favor say aye
aye okay next story Anna Wintour reveals
what she'll wear to the 2019 Met Gala
the 2019 and I don't care what she's
gonna wear I care about the theme the
2019 Met Gala is fast approaching
Anna Wintour already has an alpha picked
out she told CNN's Christiane Amanpour
that her outfit will include millions of
feathers the statement is a reference to
a quote from author Susan Sontag
the theme is notes on camp and Susan
Sontag said camp is a woman walking
around in dress made of three million
feathers I don't know that that's camp I
know that I guess they're going for the
camp more like outdoorsy woodsy kind of
vibe but I'm just like loving a
relatable theme like it when it was
comme des Garcons I really have no idea
what that means and I also thought it
was common to Garcons like the whole
time so I'd
hated that like now at least it's an
English word which I can understand
Buckingham town and it's me like I'm
gonna show up dressed as a [ __ ]
s'more with like a bonfire coming out of
my ass I'm gonna dress up as a
councillor snitch I'm gonna dress up as
American camera mmm Italian campers a
little more chic yeah French camper I'm
really looking forward to sees me French
campaign to see how the celebrities are
gonna ruin the scene because like
there's so many ways I can go about it
and like an obvious way like but they're
also interpretive and artistic they'll
take it to be like the camp or they'll
make it like the oh I got it
someone's gonna do something no I was
just gonna make a terrible joke I'm not
gonna make it anymore like if you're not
wearing Sophie shorts you're off theme
right if you're if you're solo pants
don't flip over and have something cute
on the back not D and if you're not
wearing sneakers you're not in theme and
if your hair isn't graded you are not
indeed you know if you don't have a now
Jean water about or any any water bottle
you're not in feet and honestly if
you're not sweating you're not into you
know you're wearing a sports bra you're
not in themed totally if you don't have
color or face paint on you are not in
theme if your back isn't broken from
sleeping on a wooden bed you're not in
zine I think that's it I keep I could
always keep going and if you don't have
the [ __ ] greatest counselor in
America honestly they should invite
counselor smidge if Anna Wintour had one
sense about her she would invite
counselors managed to camp neck ala that
don't so funny and if it's not like
camping boat okay I have something to
tell you don't ruin that it's camp
themed all right don't hate no it is
can't no don't look at the comments I
want to tell you
someone has translated for us the word
camp they are using not to mean like
summer camp it's more campy like
flamboyant more like drag attire it's a
fashion term for flamboyant
so then why wouldn't you say drag queen
campy is what people are saying why
wouldn't you say notes on flamboyance
okay I have to say I'm really
disappointed that I can sound more like
a Mecca I'm disappointed that we're not
getting a summer camp theme but this is
still a really good theme and I hope
that like one person didn't watch it to
a sane doesn't know that that's what
that means
and dresses their people as campers
right like Elle Woods or like oh my god
I mean I didn't Beverly Hills what am i
next opportunity came and Courtney's
showing up with all the kids dressed as
little campers with like Kim Kardashian
with a K and if someone
show up with a clipboard you're not in
thief ha oh my god that's such a better
theme this is still a good theme it's
better than comme des Garcons cuz I
still didn't know what that man yeah
this sounds a little bit more tangible
for the average citizens means a glitz
glam makeup but good I'm gonna
isn't that what Matt Galland me you but
everyone's always showing up with their
understate of dresses and very nice you
know but like even Kim when she just
wore that white dress and [ __ ]
Kendall wore a jumpsuit no camp you know
what they probably saw all the looks in
the past eaters being like why is nobody
putting on makeup and then being like
you know what let's make it the most
extreme theme a drag theme i but it's
but then my women they make a drag seem
just like I think they just wanted to
slap a nicer word on it I think I can
taste like camp it doesn't mean anything
else other than like campy camp ok no
actually I changed my mind I'm really
excited about this like ok flamboyance
like love call it that but wait if
you're calling it camp
you better have a [ __ ] coke chuggy
because it's fashion and I guess
everyone there knows that camp means
flamboyant but we don't because nobody
invites us to things I don't know I want
to see [ __ ] Oliver Aroostook from
bomb on dressing all the girls in town
on camp yeah oh my god that's so cute
like the ribbed shorts maybe this will
inspire a brand or a designer to do like
an entire camp themed collection because
when he saw the invitation he thought it
was that as well and there was like a
little disappointed to find out that it
wasn't that but then automatically felt
inspired to just do like entire
collection around like bonfire s'more
vibes and have a cologne that smells
like bonfire love that I don't know any
Tommy Hilfiger for the job I think yeah
be dressing on scampers or Ralph Lauren
like more like American right I like
that plaid vibe but then there's Italian
camper maybe maybe miskeen album yes
you're safer flair yeah you save her
safe yesterday course I did and you
didn't even pick up on it no I didn't
it's an ode to Elle Woods a little
Versace camper a little verse taste
never hurt nobody
yeah well I'm looking forward to seeing
what everyone pulls out of their hat and
hopefully there's some confusion on the
carpet cuz that would be funny that
would be wonderful if I see one Sophie
short I'll die a happy woman I know that
I won't but maybe someone can wear it
under their dress for me it's like some
if some model is watching or something
right now who's like going with a
designer like please just wear Sophie
short yeah or so be should really be
like the sponsor of the entire event
they should are like Modell's Sports
Authority totally Paragon sports love
that okay next up emilia clark says
instagram photo shopping apps should be
banned easy for you to say
totally emilia clark is not a fan of
photoshop the Game of Thrones actress
opened up about the pressures of social
media in a new interview with Miss vogue
what's mrs. Oakes ounds like something
we could get into because I sounds like
someone who's trying to be Vogue but has
absolutely no affiliation no it sounds
like it has a feel it's like teen though
oh no they have teen vogue quote I think
that we can find our inner beauty by
looking inwards and not outwards she
told the magazine seriously now we're
really screwed because we've got the
editing we've got the shading we got all
that bloody nonsense they don't look
like that
ain't nobody look like that she went on
to mention the privilege that comes with
being a celebrity calling certain images
fake and pointing out that famous people
can afford professionals to help with
their diet exercise hair and makeup at
Neiman's banks Clark even in a minute
that some of her past movie posters have
been heavily retouched quote hey guys
ain't got no double D's I'm very happy
with what I've got and it's not what
you've put on that poster she claims she
told producers however the star also
pointed out that it's not just famous
people who edit their online
personalities and looks what I struggle
with the girl next door also editing
their pictures Clark continued it's not
right where is that human interaction I
think that the apps that make people
airbrush themselves and look thinner or
look clearer skin should be banned I
don't think [ __ ] should be on the phone
for young people I do not agree with it
I do not like it it doesn't make me feel
good I don't do it on my Instagram i
filter sure everybody's got a filter but
ain't no way that I'm gonna retouch out
stuff she just draws a line at filtering
that makes no sense I totally disagree
with what she's saying the first half of
the interview I agree with like the fact
that every celebrity who graces a cover
of a makeup I mean of a magazine or like
a makeup ad and they look nothing like
themselves like that is terrible and
like the fact that they think the only
way to sell makeup is to have everyone
not look like themselves I agree but a
private citizens personal choice to just
edit a photo of oh my god
edit a photo is not Emilia Clark's
business I like her being judgmental and
condescending I'm the girl next door who
might be insecure about something and
just wants to fix it look please that's
such [ __ ] that's so not the same
right and if you take away the girl next
door's editing apps okay
celebrities magazines are still editing
pictures so then there's just even more
of a gap between the way that they we
perceive that they look right way that
we feel and not only that like if
I edit my picture to the best that I can
look like thin skin blah and then I look
at a celebrity's virgin I'm like hey
like you know we're not so different but
if they get to their pictures and we
don't know and it's just like okay Larry
the Queen and we're the sorry people's
but she doesn't even call out here is
the celebrities who do it to themselves
they're like a celebrity's we're victims
they're always changing our pictures for
us
please [ __ ] get celeb face every single
celebrity on their own on their own
personal Instagram edits photos because
it's a personal choice I hate this like
judgmental nature around editing photos
if I shop for a magazine and they wanted
to make me thinner like that's mean
because I didn't ask you to do that but
if it's my personal choice as it is or a
celebrity regardless if you're famous or
not it's a personal choice to facetune
your photos and they do that so people
who are like judgmental about that I
[ __ ] hate like good on you you accept
all your flaws you're amazing you're
better than all of us but we're not
everyone's like that so because you
think you're better we have to look ugly
in pictures please that's such [ __ ]
these are still not the same
I will anyone who equates magazine
airbrushing to private citizens face
tuning no right and you know what when I
face human pictures I never accidentally
give myself three legs right so you guys
can calm down with the photo I don't
take you for a fool no but like they get
out of control cause I'll take a picture
where they like your head in wine they
like your arm and the other that I could
horse on there and they put all together
and that's a fake person yep you know I
take the loo the one shot the one that's
the least worse and make it better yeah
please emilia clarke okay then it's like
everyone will still have to be
accountable when you we see you in
person it's like you want to play you
want to return your all that okay but
I'm still gonna meet you one day if you
want to live in the real world if you
want to be that girl who's a
recognizable from her photos then that's
your [ __ ] cross to bear and you know
it's your personal choice and I'm okay
with that personal choice Danny I do
love her though me too I think if I was
never gonna and be like we can are all
beautiful I think I just think it too
you know what like I someone who she's
talking about me look I face human
photos no
I choose I actually don't think she's
talking about you
is the amount that we used a student
like we still look like real people on
our instagrams like I don't think that's
what's upsetting her it's like these
Instagram thoughts said it's like when
you look at celeb face and it's the
paparazzi you took a picture of them on
the beach and then you see the picture
that they post in and it's two different
people yeah and it's like that picture
that they put the the common people
didn't see that paparazzi picture but
they saw the one right Instagram and it
makes people feel bad like how come my
waist doesn't look like how come I don't
look like right this an hour but because
that person doesn't look like it either
right and like good on on Denari it's
like great you feel like you're
comfortable to take photos and not edit
them because you have a full hair and
makeup team and a staff and a trainer
and a nutritionist so you're the exact
type of person that you're making fun of
knowing she's saying that she's owning
it but she's saying we should all you
know even so it's easy for her to say if
I had a trainer and a nutritionist and
all that I could say that too we should
all embrace now that [ __ ] cuz I'm fat
and I don't want to be so yeah also like
freedom of face tunes yeah totally I
believe it's up the bill of rights it
should be should be you know the the
Constitution really needs to it's a
living that a ball needs to evolve at
the time totally and I think it should
be excluded as a madman night if we took
it to the to the Supreme Court
I just this narrative of like people
like looking down on people who edit
their pictures as a choice is is it's
wrong I don't agree she has a little bit
of an argument when it comes to like the
industry like demanding that every photo
in a magazine be airbrushed to
perfection that's correct
but if it's my personal choice on my own
Instagram with my own photo to edit the
way that I want you're not allowed to
say anything also you know what industry
you guys go first you stop doing it
first then we'll do any our follow suit
because then we're all on the same plane
agreed it's it's great point awesome our
faith in final stories a little bit of a
departure from the morning toast but I
saw it and it seemed like really big
news and I could just see the astronauts
at NASA like really seeing this news and
them being like why does no one care oh
yes I would like to put forth then a
black hole picture has been captured for
the first time in a space breakthrough
I'm trying like I'm really trying to
care I know I know me too
and even if
at the end of this we don't care like
and every time I think of a black hole
I'm holding I'm reading history and I
just want to share it I just think of
that movie the theory of everything and
it's like so sad I don't know what he
did to that wife unforgivable I'm not
quite sure what the black hole is but
hopefully the science correspondent for
The Guardian can let us know okay
astronomers have captured the first
image of a black hole heralding a
revolution in our understanding of the
universe's most enigmatic objects okay
we know about enigmas wrapped in rubber
little ZM cash the picture shows a halo
of dust and gas tracing the outline of a
colossal black hole at the heart of the
my seer 87 Galaxy 55 and light-years
from Earth the black hole itself a
cosmic trapdoor from which neither light
nor matter can escape is unstable but
the latest observations take astronomers
right to its threshold for the first
time illuminating the event horizon
beyond which all known physical laws
collapse the breakthrough image was
captured by the event horizon telescope
a network of eight radio telescopes
spanning locations from Antarctica to
Spain and Chile in an effort involving
more than 200 scientists we have a
picture of it up on the screen
sorry that was truly like one of the
most boring things ever and I've missed
the whole thing I'm gonna please fee
please be done why it's interests onct
and these astronauts work so hard it's
like that's true they do are hard
scientists this network of telescopes of
spanning eight locations from Antarctica
to Chile who knew they were working
together it's exciting it's exciting I'm
happy for that I think things like they
said it's like you know we all are
divided States countries but we're at
the end of the day we're all part of
earth and human race and it's at it's
like and the black hole I don't know if
it's a negative or a positive thing but
it's like the White Walkers we can all
be fighting the war of five so truce but
we need to stop killing each other so we
have an army for the black hole I think
a black hole is good I don't know
something that where it's like neither
light nor matter can escape so it's like
if you got stuck in a black hole you can
never get out oh my god but you die no
matter that's literally my worst
nightmare like being alive forever with
nothing yeah but there's no food so
eventually you'll die okay well that's
also my worst nightmare talking about
starvation it's the worst kind of death
is it
yeah totally cuz like how long does it
take you like a month
a long time depends on who you are - and
it depends how much you're eating
regularly for me like I'm going from
like 3,000 calories a day like six
months to die yeah so gameofthrones
really opens your eyes to all the
horrible ways to die yes they're very
creative in that way and I think in
watching I think the worst sets other
than like well like [ __ ] Ramsay did -
Theon and just like leaving like that
sort of torture is death my fire even
though the Lord of Light says it's the
purest death right but are you alive
sounds hard when Theon Greyjoy tried to
cut the head of Sir Roger Roderick and
he like couldn't do it cuz he wasn't
strong enough so he like went a bunch of
times and it's still in come on and they
picked it and then kicked it kick the
head off that was really bad that might
be the worst you're right oh my god that
was that was horrible cuz like he was
getting his head cut off and the guy
doing it like wasn't strong enough so he
was like with a half a head for a while
but I just got like a chill in my lower
back just in time for blocky we talked a
lot about what's kept - like what's he
have - who's he dating is rumored to be
with Christina right but people worship
in Hana Hana G now because she was said
out of podcasts that she thinks he's
really cute and they're both going to
paradise right but that's what like it
definitely won't work out she likes it
like it never works out like that it's
always the one that you don't expect so
no but this she'll date someone in
paradise think she'll watch an interview
in hindsight and be like that awkward
that like she said publicly that she
thought he was cute it's a different
boyfriend if you're watching on YouTube
feel free to comment 400 sorry oh my god
told I told ya really Hills
that's where today opening was weird I
was like they went from 25 24 hours
later and then all of a sudden there I
tranqs with no explanation I thought
they were gonna go back over what
happened in the 24 hours it was just
like I just thought it was weird like
that we're giving this pertinent airtime
to Lisa's kitchen
who gives a [ __ ] oh my god how many
times is she gonna say she told me she's
she's acting literally like someone was
beheaded in the kitchen she's remodeling
her kitchen probably sending over a
hundred thousand dollars because she got
in a fight with Kyle like she did what
she's acting like that's the reason why
she did it but she was talking about it
before LBP stands do you not see through
that like this joke that she's made
repeatedly it looks like she makes it
next week - and she takes the
sledgehammer up theon greyjoy style cuz
she doesn't have the strength I have the
funniest thing
in the very beginning in the episode
she's like you know it's like yes it's
she was saying that that someone said
something to her that wasn't nice
she's a kiss it's an offhanded comment
but you know those add up and that's
what people have been saying about Lisa
forever her British jabs it's like one
jab Punjab Punjab they all adapt so
someone says something a little
off-color to you and now you're mad you
have all people have literally the least
amount of ground to stand on when it
comes to jobs you read the jab Queen
that's the only reason you should be
writing that ugly crown on your head
because you're the queen of jabs and
that's it you're not the queen of
Beverly Hills you're a [ __ ] and I hate
you and I was getting literally
infuriated watching in fury and and and
they did the poll on my Traven's ID
who's [ __ ] whose side are you on
they're trying to get her show up to the
reunion because they heard that she's
not going they're kissing her ass and
they did not accept a caller they didn't
know her head Vanderpump dog I need time
that she's been on Vanderpump rules
I mean any time she's gonna watch
outside this season she's been alone and
that's never happened she wasn't always
alone she's alone that's not she's been
alone before before but not exclusively
she's been on that twice just for this
season completely alone
and probably pre-recorded because no one
like she wouldn't even go with anyone
cuz then they would have to hold her
accountable because she can say crazy
stuff and I'm sure the girls that were
watching at home shouting like that's
not what happened yeah but no one's
there to hold her camel and Annie is
treading lightly with her but he was
going a little bit he knows yet knew he
was holding her a little bit accountable
but like not all the way because that's
not his role it's on his role and they
have a relationship outside Beverly
Hills where they're both producers on
Vanderpump rules so they have like out
their co-workers but I did love how
Bravo like shows that she got flowers
from John's house so like you know
they're trying to show us the full
picture
so John when we have starting to hurt
and he like he seems like somebody talks
really close to you
totally and I mean he was like looking
like in like inside of her feels don't
look like he was right now I let her and
I was just like this doesn't look I've
never I hate talking to people like that
who are like sew up the area I need a
few paces back just in case my breath is
bad and you'll never know and when
Denise was at her party for 45 minutes
sitting by herself like I've never
wanted to hug someone so much in my life
I felt so bad for and you know what
that's like like with a new group of
friends where you literally don't know
anyway
and the one person you know doesn't show
up but you're also Denise Richards so
it's sitting there alone but everyone
knows so see you are looking at you and
clearly what a good friend for even
staying what a good friend for even
going in the first place when she had
these plans for it's her party they all
went to Beauty and Essex for her to
celebrate her wedding yeah and you know
who wasn't happy about that
Camille right I can't stand Camille I
might like her less than Lisa Vanderpump
I just don't understand her mo I don't
reading apologizing about the teeth
thing she should've apologized that was
mean I do understand her mo because it's
like no it's so obvious today on the
show exactly her getting off the show
was the worst thing to ever happen to
her now that she's tasted it every
moment she gets on camera she tries to
make it the most extreme ball gag teeth
moments and that they put it on the
commercial and they like her and that
people remember her the fact that she
has the ball gag in the clubhouse it's
her greatest accomplishment she will do
anything just to sit on the show the
worst thing that ever happened to me was
Denise Richards getting married because
he was supposed to be her wedding season
yep but it's like we already got a
wedding I don't from a main cast member
from a celebrity who by the way I'm
really liking me too I am turning on I
am like turning the other way on her and
like I'm cuz they stopped talking about
Charlie Sheen and yeah I'm seeing her
personality and she's just a smart girl
I always like a smart girl and it's like
I don't feel the need for I'm not crazy
another wedding this season no totally
but the fact that its destination helps
because I am craving a tour trip yeah
and I thought they were gonna announce a
trip soon because they were like well
they even come to celebrate your wedding
so let's go to dinner I thought they
were gonna go to a trip yeah the dinner
was cute Camille was that was wrong
you're not you can't make fun of
someone's like physical appearance that
was really mean and I don't know why she
said that cuz her she's firmly taken the
side of Lisa Vanderpump thank you say
it's like she just wanted to be included
with the group who was hating on the
savanna problem yeah it's really
uncomfortable for the other girls like
no one's gonna stand up at least of
MphasiS they're all fighting with her
but they also aren't gonna like love
Camille and I don't know how I would
like they definitely didn't handle it
right by like what I think uncovering
their faces but there was no right way
to handle it was it was honestly
horrifying it was I loved Lisa Rinna and
I can't believe that people are turning
on her so much this season like claiming
that she's behind this whole thing which
is like the dumbest theory ever
she's definitely loving the takedown
because she has been Lisa Vanderpump's
punching bag for three seasons straight
so she's liking it from the side and
it's like we saw in tonight's episode
done last night's episode that Rinna
- Vanderpump about the happy birthday
pills thing that was crazy I didn't know
I don't know that and then when asked
about it on watch what happens live the
fact that Lisa Vanderpump was being such
a victim like and then she said it was
three months before and then she's
thinking room the post at weeks after so
was it weeks or something and she was
like in that moment watch Rinna's take
on their conversation and then watch
Lisa Vanderpump on watch what happens
live and that is a prime example of her
duplicity and her conning there is the
average American viewers there is no way
in hell Lisa Vanderpump I mean Lisa
Rinna put that up to make fun of her
brother suicide that is still crazy one
she's not an evil person Lisa Vanderpump
and I mean Lisa Rinna and I don't even
think an evil person would do that to it
makes sense why stupid person it makes
sense why at least so we're gonna put
that up we get it the jokes she's the
pill girl she's always talking about
pills she took this thing that they
tried to pin on her and made it like her
shtick and it's funny totally makes
sense why she did it and I understood
the second I saw the photo I didn't need
an explanation three her sister died of
an overdose she would never make light
of an overdose especially cuz she's
spoken about it so openly with agent
South Sudan was on the show like there's
just no way and the fact that Lisa
Vanderpump could in any way have
interpreted like that is just proves the
way Lisa Vanderpump thinks right and
also the fact that she would continue to
put forward that it could have been that
way is so that's evil yeah also we've
been watching the show for a few months
now and I didn't know that that either
her brother passed away like we do but
it was it was an overdose so we know
that Rinna and Vanderpump aren't that
close and it's very private very
possible and probably shirt as fact that
she did not know that that's how he
passed away a never once for one second
occurred to me that it could have been
about anything else other than the bag
of pills I just like Vanderpump was
really pissing me off on Chinese episode
on watch what happens live and the fact
that she hasn't been watching the
episodes it's like what are you coming
to speak on you don't even know what's
airing totally it's like you didn't do
the reading no you didn't do the reading
exactly don't raise your [ __ ] hand no
totally it's it's not fair actually and
she's supposed to be writing blogs
how was she writing blogs if she's not
watching episodes and by the way no
matter whose side you're on in this
entire thing you cannot deny that the
fact that the way that Ken raised his
voice at a woman got in her face and
threw him threw her out of his house is
even if you're an ugly piece den you
have to be able to own that and the fact
that they are now taking Kyle making
light of goodbye Kyle as an attack on
Lisa and Ken is the craziest thing I put
up on my Instagram then I was leaving
Orlando and I said goodbye Kyle and I
got DMS from Lisa Vanderpump Stan's
being like that is bullying so let me
just I want to understand the mind of a
deranged herb demented Lisa Vanderpump
then so me quoting something from
housewives is bullying okay but Ken and
Lisa screaming in a woman's face Kyle
was so calm I keep watching him back I
don't know how she didn't cry she was so
calm she never once raised her voice
they were cursing screaming through her
outer brows that's not bullying but me
quoting from housewives is I have a
question then and Ken raising his voice
in a woman's face and screaming and
spitting in her face that's not bullying
so and her saying goodbye Kyle is you're
demented
every time I say WOW Bethenny just wow
Bry bullying Ramona no every time you
say clip-clip are you making fun of
LuAnn cuz that's what that was directed
at every time a say you're such a [ __ ]
liar Camille am i making fun of Kyle no
it's so crazy like Jerry and I'm just
I'm literally I'm not really shocked
that Lisa Vanderpump has managed to turn
all these things now in her own in her
own direction but I'm surprised how many
people are following you guys and the
toasters I'm so disappointed I mean the
toasters up for the most part on the
right side of this but just it's the
country that poll was complete [ __ ]
complete [ __ ] I hope that they bring
dick just to make her keep just to keep
her in the seat yeah because she has all
the power right now if she doesn't show
up to the reunion it'll be very
lackluster because the entire season is
about but then she won't be on the next
I kind of hope she doesn't chop through
the ring because it's confirmed show me
the next season I mean I think
regardless even if she does show up this
is her last season she the one thing
Lisa Vanderpump can't do is be
accountable and what everyone is trying
to get her to do now is take
accountability for her role in this
fight and that's the one thing she can't
do and she will not show up I don't know
I think she could show up to the reunion
it could get bloody and they all agree
to disagree and then next season they
let her bring a close friend on that
happened with Guri Guri came in as her
in her pocket but you know what maybe
they want to do this season maybe they
let her that Lisa needs to be on the
channel and the more that I think about
it the more as much as she's so wealthy
okay
like just let's see the receipts also
she needs the show she needs an
accomplice she just opened a new
restaurant like she needs to be at the
top of the page this isn't the time to
fade into irrelevance a totally she
needs this show and she'll do but it end
it's Oprah Diaries and I think she will
come on the reunion but I wouldn't be
surprised if they're like okay you know
what if you come back next season we'll
let you bring Pandora's oh my god
totally that would be so horrible saying
it's horrible but I'm just saying that's
an interesting theory I like where your
head like I can't able to yep whoever
it's the new housewife next season we'll
definitely and Lisa Vanderpump is there
it will be a friend of Lisa's because
she's not gonna come into another season
alone right like Kathryn Edwards like
someone who were Camille is her friend
now because Camille was had a meal at
full housewives they'll make it yeah and
that would be the debt would be paid and
and Camille with a Lisa Vanderpump toe
and she wouldn't turn on there cause
like that song she wanted it to be a co
housewife I know she'll say some crazy
[ __ ] totally cuz she's been around
forever she knows stuff Wow honestly to
Susan so and then know everyone's being
like this is boring puppy gated let's
move on it's not about that anymore it's
so good this is the best season ever
this is about the reckoning and if you
don't see it then you're then Julie then
get glasses yeah okay now it is time for
block a if you're watching on the
YouTube channel please drop a comment
for Blake portsmen from the
bachelor/bachelorette if you have any
questions for him we will do our
absolute best to get them to you we are
going to take a quick break and then we
will move that we will be back with
blank petition to get LVP out and Lala
in yes bye
you
oh okay we are back with someone I just
have burning questions for mostly having
to do with his Instagram handle welcome
Blake also known as vilaça can you like
okay so once I started questioning your
Instagram handle
obviously everyone explain it I'm gonna
say this while I solve a key & peele
skit that's correct
team feels good now your Instagram
famous now do you think it's time for a
change
no people have wanted me to change my
name I know thank you it looks like your
name is Blake hey hey it looks like your
name is like B luckily like all the
people I can pass season like my agent
every is like change it to Blake doc yes
if you can find him like no block it is
your gun I respect that and people who
get it love it you know right but there
are few of those people I know I don't
you had to put up the video on the scale
oh you should leave that link in your
bio
yeah you're looking for a totally what
are you doing here in New York oh so I
am doing a Q&A session at fi t I like
the t-shirt I think you should wear this
yeah
just change your undies I know jeans if
you want to you wash your jeans yeah you
don't want them to think No so you're an
interesting guy
thank you because you came in second
Verbeck is hard but you're also you know
now hanging out with everyone and you're
seeing Becca and Garrett sometimes is
that weird like there are moments there
are seasons where you know who's gonna
win and there are seasons when you know
the person who lost like doesn't really
care right exactly I wasn't shocked but
I think the world was really shook and I
think you were shook as well yeah yeah
so and I don't think no offense you're
that good of an actor I think it was all
real yeah no so what is that like now
just hanging out and and seeing back
hanging out a lot and having to follow
along on their journey yeah so I there
was never any bad blood between
ever like it was not it wasn't I mean I
had watch a couple seasons back and
forth I know sometimes he up to an F
ones don't get along but me and carrot
were pretty good friends Terrell so
there's never any blood blood with
Garrett and I mean it there are awkward
moments we've hung out now twice roughly
for a decent amount of time each time
and yeah there's some moments that are
pretty awkward I remember we were
sitting backstage watching for the
finale you're watching the finale you
know we're like watching on like a
little TV beforehand yeah and there was
a moment when Colton was saying like
word-for-word the exact same thing that
ga'head said to me you know it was kind
of cringe where they as I was sitting
there like I don't think other people in
the room realize that it's awkward but
like I know that she'll like but it's
not like we're adults right looks like
I'm not gonna like hold it against her
for following her heart I would never do
right and a lot of people yeah and a lot
of people were championing you to be the
bachelor which didn't happen
disappointingly but if you had been cast
and you had gotten this crop of women
who do you think would be who wouldn't
because there are people ship you and
Hannah G and obviously we ship energy
with anyone who makes her happy because
we're obsessed with her here so I'm
assuming you're gonna go on paradise and
thus I mean she's gonna go on paradise
so what's that gonna look like oh yeah
so when this cast was first when I first
saw the casts circle in season I was
like you know I was like I was very
excited I'm turning 30 like two weeks
okay so I was like how was very excited
I was like how did it like - I don't
wanna do paradise then of course watch
season you get to know these girls these
women and a lot of them they're a lot
better than even the ones who didn't get
a lot of screen time I still feel like
we're pretty great right but that's the
hard part in watching a season and now
especially being on it I see the editing
so yeah I get to know the top four
really well so obviously I feel like I
would get along with a lot of top four
but at the same time maybe there's some
sleepers and they were just didn't
getting a screen time
so going in if I go to paradise yeah if
I go to paradise I'll definitely go on
with an open mind I really will yes
there are a lot of people shipping and
honestly I'm suing him there are two of
them right here
well you said on a podcast that you
thought she was pretty or something yeah
this is a stunning Casa yeah that was
the first thing I've ever seen there
and then you saw the pictures the
headshots don't do the math no never do
anyone any justice but this was a real
dis man readygo thoughts on your
headshot actually I was looking your
hair looks different in person than it
doesn't but yeah I uh I remember when
the they were all coming out I was
terrified you know cuz that picture
follows you around for this but always
like tell the producers like I'm like
they're like it comes out so I was like
oh my god I was so nervous you know I
mean I came out of what is that day like
when you take the headshots are all the
other guys there so no you're still like
secluded in your hotel room that's yes
believe that was like the second day
before you go out in the limo and they
like bring you in they said I was the
first person to so I'm like a 7:00 a.m.
call time to get my headshot and they
bring you in and it's just like a big
square you walk into and they just snap
like the hundred pictures of you so I
was just doing like you know shoulders
like yeah it's a weird then you go back
and do those weird question Q&A there oh
yeah yeah no but then they use it
against you on a date in the word but my
biggest fear is being a billionaire and
having a perfectly no you said your
biggest fear is having a book say that
you couldn't I said oh yeah had this
conversation before Asia my biggest fear
is just being on the ground at all time
and never leaving the house well
speaking of Christina and then there
there's been a lot of speculation about
you and miss Christina Schulman and
honestly it started in our Facebook
group because somebody saw you guys out
together and so yeah really our Lord
that morning toasters there the hour
whispers yes and they're just protecting
around so we're going on what's going on
there no we did yeah we definitely we
dated like I'm not gonna act like we
were just like flirting when she came to
dinner and visit me a couple times but
it didn't it didn't really work out I
was so very strange point in my life I
was like right after right right after
not being a bachelor
I was officially announced that mean
and I didn't realize what my life is
gonna turn into and like what like as
far as being busy and traveling and
having you know all these crazy
opportunities and I just felt like I
couldn't be there for her the way she
wanted me to and vice versa she realized
that - she has been in this for a long
time - you know a long time so she knows
what my life is about change into and so
it was never we I mean we respect each
other a ton there was a lot of
communication throughout we were honest
with each other and at the yeah at that
point it was just like you know I didn't
give you what you want and she was like
you can't give me what I want so and
then you were also spotted with Jen
Savin Easter's loves her you were like
okay yeah she's great
we literally just had drinks like that
position I think so no you can't even
fight without the toaster it was so
funny because I remember when because I
remember we like went up like this she
so I was in Nashville for a bit for a
watch party for one of the best
performers episodes and she happened to
be at the bar and saw my flyer and she
was like hey you wanna go - I saw you're
in town you wanna grab a drink and I was
like sure why not yes imagination yeah
we had a drink and she's like let's go
to another bar so is like okay and then
Asuna rocked in the bar like I saw
people recognize me yes and then I saw
that person taking that picture do you
feel like a pressure to stay single
right now so that you can go on bachelor
in paradise or if you met someone you
would you turn down that opportunity -
no I would definitely turn down after a
bachelor in paradise is terrifying
yeah terrifies me it looks hard on Heath
oh that's good in him no I don't know
it's terrifying to go back Network cuz
they have your whole life in their hands
like they really do but can change they
can ruin it they can make like it's it's
scary and how am i that's right
journey ended obviously is scary like I
don't want to have to go through all
that again so yeah that seems like
best-case scenario it's like you just
got your heart broke and as opposed to
like America turning on you that would
be yeah both would be really bad well
engaged what I guess all right yeah I'm
never and honestly you spend more time
with that yes like way more time
see them at their worst and sweatiest
you a be filled from Instagram wants to
know would you ever date a physical
therapist from Boston named Abby people
just try and set you up now with anyone
your website yes yeah and like sisters
and daughters and yeah it's pretty it's
are great how do you go on dates how are
you want any dating apps not on any
dating apps that would be I think dating
has to be really hard but I will admit
that like I've gone on a couple dates
and it's it's strange like I remember
being on one day and I was at the
restaurant and like people were snapping
pictures from across the bar you know
and she's new bachelor nation it was
like a normal person and she was like
does this happen all the time it's
awkward yeah unfortunately it does like
it's something that you have now it's a
conversation I have to have at that
person right okay by the way isn't an
article up on us because the morning
toasters are for sure yeah most your
name no kidding
we got um hold on wait this is a good
question it just slipped my mind just
give me ten seconds um it was wait [ __ ]
no it was really good it was about
whatever I'm Colton Cassie what are your
thoughts on them
oh they're so nice you hang out with
them this weekend in Aspen together all
of us know
are you not know I gotta say Church so
babe are you okay I've never been to a
church but I love this music
I just really just like it's got a body
experience it's so fantastic I'm gonna
love it so much
okay anyway casting Colton um I remember
I saw its it started I talked to Colton
I had dinner probably about two days
after he got back with him i sat down
with him and I could tell he was like
[ __ ] that I mean because that just
environment is just like I could see it
you know in him but I could tell also
that he was he was happy with how it
ended at the time I was I didn't know
the exact details of how it ended
because even the spoilers hadn't really
come out yet two days after got back I
look good you find out how it ended I
mean I had an idea of how it ended when
reality Steve posted it got that but I
didn't realize like he and I'll give him
credit he like he was really good about
not telling me yeah like very good like
he even like there's a couple times
where he totally lied to me listen I
know
contract everything totally you do not
want to I knew who had won pretty early
on but I know the yeah how they got
there but I think they were engaged no I
knew they were happy that were engaged
but I'll tell you what he seems they
seemed very high he seems infatuated
with her which is all you can really ask
for yeah you know but I'm excited to see
their dynamic - yeah I've met her on
like FaceTime a couple times with him
but a better person no I'm not mad or in
person yet so I'm excited to see their
dynamic in person has he like signaled
out anyone for you from his season that
he thinks he would get along with not
really actually cuz I asked him I was
like did you see anybody and which is
super weird to ask like your friends who
which one your ex-girlfriends way um and
he really wasn't like anybody in
specific he's but he was like there's a
lot of I'm a pretty high energy guy and
like I enjoy to have a good time it's
like a lot of women are very fun mm-hmm
I was like good good so what are your
GM's like I imagine they're quite
bustling bustling me yeah it's a
bustling metropolis it's weird do you go
through the GM's cuz I know that you're
gonna get a lot after this everyone
people just want to know if they have
any chance of it getting open when I
posted that morning toast or the morning
toast on my I've got a lot of dams I
didn't really yeah thanks guys to make
us look cool thank you all no but uh I
don't like all like scroll everyone
swallow like click on one here there
it's really douchey of me but now I can
look for blue checkmarks uh say don't
take anything is Jason thar take
advances I know never seen him during
the day with his shirt off in the subway
he doesn't eat garlic right nothing I've
seen Edith I haven't we totally think
he's a vampire just it's a it's a hit in
theory but speaking of Jason Tariq
you've been spending a lot of time with
him and Kaitlyn yes they seem very happy
together
seems very great together they bring out
like the best parts of each other it's
so fun to see and there's so much alike
it's insane
yeah it's insane like I remember he told
me you know I kind of knew before right
before he sacked your bus advantage so I
just totally see him with his like
trench coat just like corner people in
back alleys like stuck in them this part
is on the show of his hair the way it
was yeah I get it I could see up I'm his
haircut I thought when he got his hair
cut I was like he's for sure the
bachelor does he look back on that
haircut with regret good question I'll
have to I gotta get him on here I should
sir I mean because he's so East Coast
banker like so when he was on the I'll
be honest I was super surprised with how
far he made it on the show because I
never would be saw but I mean he knows
that like I never really saw their REIT
their connection Becca and Jason's
connection but clearly there was one
like no one watching back but like you
didn't get a date the first week which
is I can imagine that's right gotta be
so hard so they're really like